White House press secretary Sean Spicer
has apologized for his Hitler comments
and admitted he screwed up that's what
he said yeah I don't think Spicer
learned his lesson though because he
then said even Hitler didn't screw up as
badly as I did didn't really should stop
talking about it he just keeps talking
about Hitler yeah they asked about the
weather is like it's raining like
Hitler's out there take it easy
would you have a Denny's I have a Hitler
yeah a lot of crazy stuff going on if
you probably heard about this after
being accused of sexual harassment by
five women Bill O'Reilly announced he's
taking a vacation yeah and if there's
any justice in the world he'll be flying
United
I'm not limber enough to stand and lean
back far enough yeah well yeah have a
laptop eration i effectively mine that
no because of these sexual allegations
against him it's rumored that bill
o'reilly show may may be going off the
air for for continuity sake fox will
replace it with reruns of The Cosby Show
[Applause]
boo it's a booming area over here it's a
free show you can't boo a free show I
guess technically you can't sure sure
I'd oppose you're right you blew the
right crow - yeah big Cosby fans all
right
this weekend of course is Easter Easter
coming up of course Easter's where
christians celebrate the return of jesus
yes unfortunately this year Jesus can't
return because he's Middle Eastern and
he has been detained at the airport
what kind of name is Christ speaking of
Easter they're having trouble organizing
Easter at the White House this year yeah
that's right
instead of an a-list musician there's
going to now be a military band they say
yeah and a set of eggs there's going to
be golf balls and a set of children
there'll be old white guys babysit man a
new article says that Donald Trump has
changed the definition of the word
conservative yeah that used to mean
traditional and right-leaning
now it means batshit crazy
of course there's a non-political story
out there those are rare these days this
is strange but cases of syphilis in
Maine are skyrocketing cases of syphilis
in Maine are skyrocketing yeah state
officials are blaming poor hygiene and
[ __ ] lobsters
[Applause]
that's my sweaty hiya sailor click click
you